President Vonder line.
Welcome to the dole.
Welcome to Ireland.
But to be honest,
nobody would tank me,
I think, out there in the world,
if we use this opportunity
just to slap each other on the back.
So I'm going to raise some issues
where I think there is concern
and indeed necessary criticism
of the European Union.
This week you have,
and I support you in this,
called for tribunal to be established
to investigate the undoubted, to my mind,
undoubted War crimes of Vladimir Putin in Ukraine.
And I think we all share
in condemning the utterly barbaric,
murderous invasion by Russia of Ukraine
and support the people of Ukraine in their struggle
for self determination.
But I really have to say,
on the week when it is the International Day
of solidarity with the people of Palestine,
for you not to simultaneously call for an investigation
into the ongoing war crimes and crimes against humanity
being committed by the apartheid state of Israel
against the Palestinian people,
I really have to wonder about the consistency
of the ethics of the EU foreign policy.
It is utterly,
utterly unconscionable
that we can say,
on the one hand,
we must, and we must
investigate the war crimes and atrocities
of Vladimir Putin.
And remain silent
as you did when you spoke in June in Israel
beside the Israeli prime minister,
Naftali Bennett,
and did not say a word. Not a word.
After we've had 2 devastating reports
by Amnesty International
by Human Rights Watch.
Of 70 years of ongoing crimes against humanity.
Ethnic cleansing, apartheid,
the siege of Gaza,
a 15 year long criminal action.
Do we talk about investigating the war crimes of Israel?
No. Do we sanction Israel for these crimes
as we've sanctioned Russia? No.
Instead, we continue to give them favored trade status,
import huge amounts of gas from Israel,
deepen the relations
and engage in considerable military and defense trade
with the state that is doing this to the Palestinians.
I also find it remarkable
when we say we must break our dependency
on Russian fossil fuels and oil,
that at the very same time
we increase our imports of Saudi oil.
Ironically, the Saudi Arabia
this year has doubled its imports of Russian oil
and is effectively laundering Russian oil.
But we are now importing more
from the Saudi dictatorship,
one of the most brutal dictatorships in the world.
That just Lake
Vladimir Putin has engaged in a 15 year long war
against the people of Yemen
that has claimed the lives of 10s
of thousands of people.
And leading European states continue to arm that regime.
Indeed, you yourself,
when 02:15, went over and signed a defense
arrangement with Saudi Arabia,
when you were minister for defense in Germany.
If we are going to condemn, as we must,
the war crimes of Putin,
we must simultaneously condemn all war crimes,
all crimes against humanity,
even when they are committed by people
That the European Union perceives as allies,
like Israel or Saudi Arabia,
or those that
arm and support them.